en esta hermosa tarde de octubre de 1992
pocos sospechan que acaba de nacer una
revolución al margen del calendario
oficial de la semana de la moda de parís
un joven diseñador franco-maliense se ha
tomado el jardín de las tullerías en
aquella época la diversidad no existía
en la pasarela por eso cuando la mina
causa fundador de la marca azul y pet
hizo desfilar por las calles a un
centenar de modelos negras todas ellas
vestidas con lycra blanca reciclada el
mundo de la moda quedó paralizado en una
luminosa tarde de octubre de 1992 el
mundo de la moda fue testigo de una
revolución barbara blanca productora del
programa fue también la directora de
casting un recuerdo imperecedero y
fundacional el diseñador de su live se
adelantó mucho a su tiempo que la idea
de su liberación era la recuperación de
prendas ya fabricadas y la diversidad
fue indudablemente el primero quiero
decir en ese programa
siempre insistió mucho en vestir a todas
las mujeres ya todos los cuerpos mucho
antes que nadie y este uso de la lycra
fue el símbolo de eso de shambala veinte
años después de ese desfile considerado
como un hito bárbara plancha sigue
siendo una directora de casting
imprescindible pero ha ampliado su gama
de actividades ahora dirige una agencia
de talentos además de una marca de moda
y es una incansable defensora de la
diversidad y la inclusión
las modas discriminatorias
porque al fin y al cabo las personas que
hacen las imágenes son todas de una
clase dominante así que es cierto que
hay una narrativa un poco línea
necesariamente su clase y toda la
diversidad no tiene acceso a la creación
de imágenes acciones más siempre
contaremos la misma historia esto
podemos hablar de un techo de cristal es
cierto que en los años 90 teníamos la
impresión éramos los hijos
y un poco del movimiento negro blanco y
ahora teníamos esta sensación de que no
había límites que estábamos todos juntos
con esto que éramos iguales y que por
fin podríamos llegar a tener trabajos
creativos con bastante facilidad hachís
he tenido trabajos muy buenos ojos
apretando victimizarme pero lo que
quiero decir es que una vez que llegas a
una determinada etapa no llegas a los
verdaderos puestos de poder o los que te
permiten gestionar de tomar decisiones
si estás siempre hay un momento en el
que eres demasiado exuberante eres
demasiado
en 2019 bárbara plancha de funda con dos
socios un sello al que llama al que arte
como el nombre de la diosa griega del
valor y la proeza y esto obviamente no
es una coincidencia es una marca de ropa
de fútbol para mujeres fabricada en
europa para todos los aficionados a este
deporte
lo que más me interesó de este proyecto
aparte de la atracción que siento por la
ropa deportiva fue la dimensión
feminista y solidaria en el sentido de
que nos fijamos en los problemas de la
mujer futbolista en los países del sur
especialmente en el continente africano
el acceso de las mujeres a las
actividades de ocio es una verdadera
lucha no está ganada de antemano y más
aún para las jóvenes que juegan al
fútbol lo que más me interesa de este
proyecto más allá de mi amor por la ropa
deportiva es ese énfasis en el feminismo
y también en la solidaridad
con sus múltiples experiencias bárbara
blanca también se ha lanzado a la
consultoría empresarial su intención no
es hacerles sentir culpables lo que
sería contraproducente sino crear
conciencia de forma pedagógica de qué
diversidad e inclusión son conceptos que
van de la mano
la diferencia entre ambos es decir que
te inviten a una fiesta y te quedes
parado es la diversidad te invitan a esa
misma recepción y te convidan a sentarte
a la mesa con todos los demás
así que es cierto que a menudo se
confunden estos dos conceptos distintos
y totalmente complementarios cojo como
agente artística barba la plancha ha
notado la moda de la piel negra o
mestiza gladys gambi forma parte de su
equipo de jóvenes talentos es bailarina
coreógrafa y directora artística también
enseña a bailar a cantantes y actores
recientemente dirigió las escenas de
vals de la película biográfica sobre
gustave eiffel
llega al ensayo bueno no estaban
preparados los bailarines para verme
llegar con grandes trenzas y nada
adecuado para para ellos no era adecuado
para hacerles montar un vals
especialmente para una película que
tiene lugar en 1800
así fue nos reímos mucho me gusta jugar
con este parámetro sabiendo que aprendí
el vals de un sudafricano un bailarín de
sudáfrica porque en sudáfrica creo que
había una parte de economías inglesas
que allí era chic el vals y cuando
estaba en el conservatorio fue este
bailarín sudafricano que era negro como
yo quien me enseñó a dar mis primeros
pasos de vals a los 14 años así que ahí
lo tienes ahí estaba todo eso ahí lo
tienes eso es el arte eso es lo que el
arte puede permitir también son cosas
como esas que parecen establecidas y que
no lo son no puedo hablar realmente de
inclusión en el sentido estricto de la
palabra ya que el trabajo nos permite
hacer cosas que están un poco más allá
de mis límites éticos por así decirlo
derribar muros y tender puentes sí pero
sin querer cambiar todo a toda costa
barbara blanch a una humilde arquitecta
de proyectos perennes de apertura que
las siguientes generaciones ya no
tendrán que plasmar